we're here with Dimitri Cosmo CEO and
co-founder of open film Collins gave a
wonderful talk here you tell us more
about open films
well open phone comm is really one
portion of our business but it's a it's
a platform where we help show distribute
a lot of independent films we already
have over 5,500 library a very tough
criteria to make it onto the site and
that's because the right people are
looking into the site not just amount of
people that we have on the site or
distribution but guys like our advisory
board James Bond and Robert Duvall mark
Riedel and Scott Caan you know the guys
that could really make a difference in
independent filmmakers career so the
site was built to make sure that will
showcase the films in the best possible
way
I just qua quality wise or anything that
those are all having holidays that's
that's really easy to do but also to
distribute them and to get as many
eyeballs as possible to help them make
revenue along the way anything that we
bring into the company will share along
with a filmmaker whether it's on the
site off the site anything that has to
do with it that's it in a nutshell
pretty much we have tons of offerings I
welcome you guys to check out the site
we have various levels of memberships of
course there's free ones they give a lot
of a lot of benefits but we have some
that are for minimal fees that actually
allow you to communicate with somebody
like James Bond and get feedback on your
films and stuff like that so it's quite
exciting